what's up guys the walkers are back
walking dead we're about to give you
everything you need to get you ready for
season four by the way a lot of spoilers
dead ahead first season first episode
first scene cute little girl
turns around she's got zombie herpes
mouth deputy Rick Grimes has no choice
gunned her down and it is a long
flashback to our hero Rick falling into
a coma after being shot by armed robbers
in that coma Rick just misses the dead
becoming reanimated and his wife and kid
replacing him with his best friend I
thought it was bad when I overslept and
just got a parking ticket on street
cleaning day
Rick grabs a bunch of guns and heads to
the ATL which is now worse than Newark
and Detroit combined yeah he pretty much
hit downtown Atlanta during zombie rush
hour rick has to lock himself inside a
tank but then he meets Glenn on the
radio
dumbass Glenn helps him navigate the
hordes and then Rick meets Andrea t-dog
and everyone's favorite racist Merle
enough I got this taco bender on my ass
all day now I'm gonna take orders from
you
Merle is crazy as a [ __ ] rat so
Rick handcuffed him to a roof with that
problem taking care of everyone else
heads back to the campsite Rick finds
his family wife Laurie son Carl and he
doesn't know that his old pal Shane has
been playing daddy
not cool Shane people in the camp we
care about are Dale the obligatory old
man Carol and Merle's badass brother
Daryl shut up Rick decides to go back to
Atlanta to get his guns and save Merle
make up your mind Rick we get to the
rooftop and Merle went all 127 hours and
cut his hand off what now Rick wants to
lead the group to the Center for Disease
Control but Shane wants to go to Fort
Benning Shane
a Matt Rick in the woods not cool Shane
doesn't do it but old man Dale sees him
and has a very judgmental reaction we go
to the CDC
dr. Jenner greets them why are you here
what do you want a chance oh and one
more thing the CDC is losing power and
spin a blow-up facility live
decontamination will occur
so dr. Jenner had all this awesome
Walker research that got destroyed but
he does tell Rick a very special secret
that we have to wait a really long time
to find out they all escaped and they
drive off with very bad CG in the
background
matter of fact we could make a more
realistic looking explosion happen right
here boom season two we spent season two
on a farm long slow stretches just on a
farm almost don't talk about it but
there's still some pretty cool crap so
let's get in there we're on the road and
their Winnebago breaks down oh and guess
what here come the walkers cue Carol's
Daughter Sofia running into the woods Oh
Sofia and while we're on the subject of
knowing children there's Carl he wants
to go pet a deer and he gets shot by
Otis don't get too attached Otis don't
get too attached to anybody okay so
Sofia's missing Carl's shot just don't
raise kids during the Apocalypse
okay it sucks they get to the farm where
they meet Hershel conveniently a doctor
veterinarian who saves Carl all this guy
does is save people and then tell them
that they have to leave off my land
Shane kills Otis and leaves him for
zombie food not cool Shane oh and Lori
is prego she needs to go on Maury and
find out who's the father
Glenn hooks up with the farmer's
daughter I'll have sex with you really
pretty pimp Glenn so being a big horn
dog now Glenn wants to get freaky in the
hayloft but discovers that the barn is
full of walkers no that's almost as bad
as finding silverfish in your closet
I haven't silverfish
I didn't throw out some pants turns out
Herschel has turned his barn into a
halfway house for walkers there people
out there people who I believe can be
restored [ __ ]
so shame let's all the walkers out of
the barn kind of not cool Shane but
really a little bit and everybody takes
target practice on them used to last
walk her out of the barn little Sofia
the drama that is your first major
character death and then Dale dies
another major character death then Shane
tricks Rick to get him alone in the
woods to kill him raise your gun oh not
cool Shane
but then brick kills him huge major
character death Shane that becomes a
walker wait he wasn't bitten Karl kills
him again double major character death
Rick reveals that everyone carries the
Walker gene and you automatically turn
into a walker when you die girl that was
the secret from the CDC doctor then the
walkers swarm people are getting bit and
walkers are getting killed everybody's
getting into separate cars so crazy
no one even call Shotgun speaking of
which Hershel has a never-ending supply
of shotgun shells
Andrea left alone in the woods is saved
by female blade Michonne and we are
finally out of that farm boom season
three they've reached the prison but a
safe nice place to live but then Hershel
gets bitten ah but then brick chops off
his legs and it's just like he got
zombie diabetes t-dog dies
major character death Laurie gives birth
to Rick's baby and then bleeds to death
from her rusty Prison c-section the
major character deaths just keep coming
and then to stop her from becoming a
walker Karl puts a bullet in her head
that turned Karla to a man I guess
shooting his mom was kind of like his
Bar Mitzvah Andrea and Michonne are
taken captive by a guy called the
governor and Merle he's back and he
totally has an awesome stump for a hand
they're taken to a town called Woodberry
where people watch men pit fighting to
the death the governor has fish tanks
they're filled with zombie heads gross
weird awful guy back at the prison Rick
gets a collect call from his dead wife
and flips out and look comic fans its
Tyreese played by Cuddy from the wire
Andrea starts falling for the governor
because he's tall
Michonne she smells some bull - the
leaves Merle chases Michonne but ends up
coming back with Glenn and Maggie
instead Rick Daryl Michonne and some
character we don't need to care about go
on a night raid and save Glenn and
Maggie
Michonne takes the governor's eye and
kills his freakish Walker daughter we
are at war well three or four episodes
from now we will be at war the show
really slows down again so Rick meets
with the governor who offers a truce but
the governor is slimy er than a
[ __ ] rat he's gonna ambush Rick and
the crew with walkers the governor
sistent foils the plan by the way don't
get too attached to that guy Merle is
kicked out of Woodbury and also gives
the governor one final F you by the way
don't drink and drive then governor
shoots him he dies and becomes a walker
only to be killed by his brother no
major character death so the governor
wage is a huge attack on the prison but
gets an ass-whooping and then goes crazy
and like shoots all of his people where
did that come from
then he takes off with two buff dudes
and I'm thinking this fool is gonna be
back for blood in season four Andrea by
the way she'd been boning the governor
of this whole time terrible taste in men
the governor locks her in a room with
his zombie assistant and she dies major
character death Rick brings back all of
wood berries very young old and sick to
live at the prison and show us that
helping each other is what the
apocalypse is all about well that and
stabbing zombies in the face guys I hope
this was helpful if it was why not go
ahead and share it so what do you thinks
gonna happen in season four what major
character deaths are gonna go down leave
an answer in the comment section below
best answer I got the screen junkies
t-shirt how about that I want to thank
you for watching hit me up on Twitter
I'm Hal Rudnick wife you won't call a
new installment of people juice ooh
Beetlejuice that's a tough beetle
juicier I feel like you used to be
beetle tus look with the two beetle to
thee yeah